so now that we're getting into really
the meat of the 2022 midterm elections
we've had some primaries we have a bunch
of other primaries coming up
we are getting into the farcical
cringe stage of many of these
candidacies and we're going to look at a
couple of different candidates and ads
today
we're going to start with mehmet oz
mehmet oz is running for senate he's
running in the republican primary in
pennsylvania he's been endorsed by trump
but as we saw yesterday
in some clips from the weekend's rally
many trumpists aren't thrilled with
mehmet oz and one of the reasons that
they're not thrilled with mehmet oz
is that really he has a decade plus of
saying stuff about politics that aligns
more with the democratic than the
republican party i think memit oz is
completely unqualified
he's done quack doctor stuff on tv for
years uh he's dishonest all these
different things
but it is also true that at least some
of his positions historically have lined
up more with the democratic party than
the republican party this includes his
views on uh guns early in the pandemic
he was more aligned with the pro-science
side which was the more left-leaning
side let's be frank and he's recently
had to change a lot of these positions
and he now has a completely
it almost seems satirical ad where he's
firing guns and the thing about this is
the first level of cringe
would be someone running
and in a serious manner
having these views about guns
and doing these types of videos where
they're out on the range firing at clay
pigeons and this type of thing
the second layer of cringe is what oz is
doing which is
it doesn't even seem like it's genuine
he's pandering with this stuff even
though it doesn't align with the memit
oz that we've known for a decade so
we're going to look at the ad
and uh if you're not watching if you're
just listening
i will mention that there's a particular
shot
where it sort of looks like oz is
shooting and hitting a clay pigeon
these are like these discs that are
thrown into the air but if you look at
how it's cut it's very obvious that they
filmed him firing the weapon
and then later filmed the clay pigeon
exploding
and it's pretty damn obvious that oz
didn't hit the clay pigeon not that it
matters it's all absurd so let's look at
the ad and then we'll talk about it
my father taught me how to handle my
first gun i taught my son oliver how to
do the same
i've been shooting and hunting my whole
life so when people say i won't support
guns
they're dead wrong
boom
[Music]
other conservatives know that i'm strong
on the second amendment ted nugent rick
perry president trump but our second
amendment is not just about hunting it's
about our constitutional right to
protect ourselves from intruders or an
overly intrusive government so as your
next u.s senator i will fight for our
constitutional rights
yeah
we need the guns to protect ourselves
from an overly intrusive government sort
of like one that says there's no right
to an abortion and states can ban it uh
listen
we have a second amendment
we we have a second amendment period
right uh i support
mandatory gun training
licensing
re-licensing
mandatory insurance
eliminating the so-called gun show or
boyfriend loophole or whatever they're
calling it these days you got to have a
background check for every transaction
all we have a second amendment and i
support all of that stuff
oz has had a somewhat similar view to
that
for most of his public record
until recently and now it's very clear
that he'll say whatever the hell he has
to in order to try to win a republican
primary and this is very similar to the
trump abortion thing oz pushed
gun safety regulations most of his
public life he wrote op-eds he said we
need to we need gun control
we need to quote stop gun violence we
need to treat shootings as a public
health emergency which i agree with and
then now all of a sudden he's having to
backtrack and find and stake out this
new position remember donald trump was
pro-choice his entire life right he was
68 years old and he had been pro-choice
his entire public life up until that
point
he had no shot at winning the democratic
presidential nomination in 2016 so he
ran as a republican and he had to stake
out a position on abortion that would be
palatable to republicans so trump came
up with this awakening that he had he
knew and
he knew people around him knew
you need a story you need an explanation
as to why you were pro-choice for 68
years and now you are suddenly
anti-choice and trump's story
paraphrased was
he met a kid once i don't remember if
the kid was 12 or 16 at the time
and the kid's mother said to trump you
know
i thought about getting an abortion
and i i decided not to
and the awakening trump had was wow
i like this kid this is a good kid
abortion is bad and now i'm against
abortion for all these religious all
these different reasons that are
completely unbelievable this is kind of
a similar thing which is oz now has to
stake out uh this uh pro
wildly pro-gun position now how is the
prize is this helping him how is the
primary and how is the race going so on
the republican side
oz does appear to be winning although
it's it's within the margin of error on
average oz is ahead of the second place
candidate mccormick by two and a half
and then ahead of the third place
candidate barnett by four points
now it's almost certain
that if mccormick or barnett bowed out
the other one would consolidate a bunch
of that support
and uh might might be able to defeat oz
but that's the way it's looking right
now oz with a slight lead and then over
on the democratic side john fetterman
who is my choice although his debate
performance wasn't very good fetterman
is my choice in pennsylvania he has
opened up on an average
a 31 point lead over the second place
contender conor lamb
so it's almost certainly going to be
fetterman against whoever wins the
republican primary so that's what's
going on there we'll continue to watch
it and uh dr oz used to do surgeries on
people that's uh that's quite a thing
we continue to explore the overlap
between extreme right-wing-ism
and mental illness
and
this is a link that we can also find on
the extremes on the left as well
but it's particularly notable lately on
the right and i have for you today i'm
going to present to you a new character
this is
susan delemus susan delemus is a new
hampshire state representative
she in the
wake of the forthcoming roe v wade
decision from the supreme court that we
learned about last week
protests broke out all over the country
and
representative susan delemus showed up
at the new hampshire state house and
started screaming at the top of her
lungs
i'm a murderer i murdered my own baby
and this is serious and tragic
and it also looks like a saturday night
live skit quite frankly it's both it's
sad
and it's endlessly
uh hysterical in a way so i'm going to
play this for you she showed up and she
started admonishing the pro-choice
protesters calling them murderers and
calling herself a murderer check this
out
[Applause]
so now she's screaming shame on all of
you but then she turns the anger inward
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
i mean
it's impossible not to laugh at the
absurdity of this and also
tragically
she seems like a very unwell person and
this is a real challenge we have right
now
we have to
be
sympathetic
to
severe
illness
mental illness without diagnosing anyone
ever of course we never do that
and at the same time realize that there
is political strength behind this
nuttery i'll give you another example we
looked yesterday at this anti-vac stuff
where michael flynn and some guy named
clay i believe his name was were talking
about how
there are um
how do i even explain this
there are particles
injected into the body
in the covet vaccine
which then are which contain marburg
virus which is a filo virus in the
family of ebola
they inject you with
it's almost like standby particles of
the marburg virus
and then a 5g signal pulsed three times
in a minute will activate the particles
which are on standby
and then you will get marburg virus
that's so crazy you have to laugh at
that that's absurd it's just it's
comical it's it's a comical conspiracy
theory
but also we have to recognize
that seems like mental illness
and
it's a tough thing to do i don't know
what else can be said
uh but whatever susan delemus went
through or is going through
um hopefully she can get the help she
needs i mean i'm struggling with how to
even say this but
uh
a new hero i guess
of the
anti-choice movement i mean i'm
struggling for uh the language with
which we can really address this
properly but bizarre
and many anti-choicers saying
that's the kind of passion we need
and when i see that i see a very very
sick person let me know what you think
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
if you have thoughts don't feel
obligated you don't have to comment on
every story i also want to remind you
that memorial day monday may 30 memorial
day
we are doing a one-day
membership blowout to officially kick
off the primary season we are the
midterm rather we will be beyond many
primaries by then
we are primarily funded by our audience
we want to do everything we want to
cover the debates we want to cover
rallies we're going to have someone on
the ground at the trump rally this
weekend all of these different things
all of these different things cost money
and so we depend on your support if
you've been thinking well maybe i'll
sign up i don't hate david so much that
i wouldn't support him right uh get on
my mailing list at davidpakman.com and
then monday memorial day you'll get an
email telling you how to sign up at an
ungodly discount
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
one of the primary features and it
really is a feature for them it's not a
bug of reactionary right-wing
culture-based politics
is to create enemies
and then to argue that you are going to
fight against them and that they are
dangerous and that they are a threat to
your way of life and that they are a
threat to america and all of these
different things and one such enemy for
the modern reactionary republican is
the vague idea of communism communists
among our ranks they might be in the
house of representatives they might be
in the senate they might be in your
schools teaching your kids things
and um i have just a delightful clip for
you here
ron desantis who is the governor of uh
florida he's in the middle of a
re-election campaign he's up for for
re-election in november of 2022
he did an event called
honoring victims of communism now i'm
the first to tell you
that i am not a communist i am against
any kind of authoritarianism
uh many
uh
uh
and and when you say communist regime
some will say they weren't really
communist
many so-called or believed communist
regimes in history have been
authoritarian and i'm against
authoritarianism no matter what it is
wrapped in
and i also recognize that this is a
completely bogus event at which ron
desantis is um a virtue
signaling for lack of a better term and
this is just my favorite thing he talks
about the argentinian marxist
revolutionary leader che guevara
and he pronounces his name cheikh
quavara
he's furious with jake but he doesn't
even know his name it's this is the
epitome of everything that is wrong with
this right-wing reactionary movement
let's take a look at it you can see at a
college campus students flying the
hammer and sickle from the old soviet
union flag you will see students that
will have t-shirts with che kevara
che
vara on the t-shirts you will see
students that will idolize people
like mao zedong uh dung that to me
speaks of a tremendous ignorance
about what those individuals represented
in the now
i am not fans of the i'm not a fan of
the people that desantis is mentioning
here
but guys i mean an event honoring the
victims of communism this is just
another one of these sort of red scare
anti-communist type rants now
the the the legacy
uh of el che as we knew him in in
argentina
it's uh it's it's not a legacy that is
thrilling to me right i mean it's a he
was a revolutionary
uh guerilla leader wanted to overturn
capitalism everywhere by almost whatever
means might work
uh the whole
history of it is that guevara met the
castro brothers and joined their
movement uh in cuba to overthrow batista
and ushered in the decades and decades
and decades of authoritarian rule by the
castros and
ultimately ended up playing
uh i'm trying to to do this sort of like
as fairly as possible
controversial roles in various attempted
revolutions all over the world including
uh
unsuccessfully in congo kinshasa later
in bolivia ultimately guevara was
captured
by cia assisted bolivian forces and
executed
and uh
guevara is not a hero to me
but the virtue signaling and reactionary
fear-mongering
by desantis of you know high schoolers
and college kids who like to wear the
t-shirt
this is not a major political issue okay
florida has some serious problems
uh housing affordability crisis in
florida
median household income in florida is
34th in the country florida ranked 33rd
in opportunity
infrastructure in florida
extraordinarily problematic public
education in florida really leaves
something to be desired if you rank
states
by their equivalent hdi what's called
the human development index florida
comes in
33rd so it's not good there's all sorts
of problems in florida and desantis is
talking about jake kavara
at a memorial honoring the victims of
communism it's just absurd and um
i i might i can only imagine that if
desantis does end up running for
president uh challenging
maybe it's going to be challenging trump
we don't know what it's going to look
like in 2024
it's going to be more of the same
reactionary fear-mongering that you can
be absolutely sure of
this story i love because it's really a
bunch of different stories it's a story
about the absurd lies of the 2020
election that are still being told by
many right-wing media networks it's also
a story about really the futility of the
types of corrections that we only ever
get so what am i talking about let me
explain it to you there's a right wing
network oan so the way i kind of place
them on on a spectrum of wacky is you've
got fox news which is slightly crazier
than the republican party you've then
got newsmax which is crazier than fox
news and then you've got oan which is in
a category kind of
not really of its own but it's in a very
extreme category along with real
america's voice and those types of
channels and for months and really quite
frankly at this point it's almost years
after the 2020 election
oan was parroting and repeating and
repeating
all sorts of lies about the 2020
election hosting the most unhinged
guests to comment on the 2020 election
they have now
been uh forced to settle a defamation
suit and they issued a sort of
retraction on air but it was only 36
seconds long
and we're going to look at it the daily
beast reporting oan finally admits no
widespread voter fraud after settling
defamation suit georgia election workers
were dragged through the mud on oan by
right-wing conspiracy theorists like
rudy giuliani now the network is finally
acknowledging there was no fraud so
let's take a look at this clip we now
provide you with this updated report
from georgia officials take a listen
georgia officials have concluded that
there was no widespread voter fraud by
election workers who counted ballots at
the state farm arena but that's not what
you told us for a year and a half
november 2020 the results of this
investigation indicate that ruby freeman
and wandria shea moss did not engage in
ballot fraud or criminal misconduct
while working at state farm arena on
election night a legal matter with this
network and the two election workers has
been resolved to the mutual satisfaction
of the parties through a fair and
reasonable settlement so so there's been
a settlement understand that that's what
they saying and clearly this report is
part of that settlement
now will they go right back to
immediately spreading lies because as
often is the case
when you have such a big lie that you're
telling and the the big lie that they're
telling is
biden stole the whole thing it was
georgia michigan pennsylvania arizona
they did dumps in the middle of the
night all this different stuff
the issue here is just about the two
individuals named freeman and the other
person so they're kind of like
correcting one tiny little slice of the
story
and then they can just go right back to
fomenting all of the same lies and the
settlement should really be
you have to mention this 10 times a day
for a year in prime time and this gets
to the issue of corrections and why i
make every effort on this show to be
accurate and then when i get something
wrong i will start the next show with it
i don't i do everything i can not to
bury the correction because nobody sees
the correction right 36 seconds 12 of
which sort of really relate to the
settlement
um after a year and a half of spreading
this stuff it's just not enough it's
kind of like punching someone in the
face for three weeks in a row
and then on the last day you quietly say
i'm sorry and then you walk away and
that we're supposed to believe that
they've been made whole and that's
essentially what this is the damage has
probably been done
irreversibly in the sense that i don't
know what the numbers now are it's
probably around
20 to 30 percent of america that
believes the 2020 election was stolen by
joe biden and actually won by donald
trump
this correction on oan isn't going to
trickle down to the cult members
the settlement it almost should be like
a permanent banner that scrolls the
screen and says
we lied about 2020 biden actually won
but even the settlement isn't related to
that it's only think about how narrow
the settlement is it's
the two individuals we named
weren't involved
in funny business
in georgia
in 2020
and uh really this is a network that is
extraordinarily dangerous and the good
news is they seem to kind of be dead in
the water i don't even know that
anybody's watching oan you might
remember famously a couple months ago a
t and a couple of other cable carriers
said they're going to be dropping oan
and trump went nuts and all these people
went nuts but the hope is
that oan ends up shutting down not
because some regulator forces them to
but because everybody stops watching
that's that that's my desire and we'll
see if that happens we'll have their
quote
correction
up on our instagram which you can find
at david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be back right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show it's great to have
back on the program today coleman hughes
who's a writer opinion columnist and
host of the podcast conversations with
coleman uh coleman it's great to have
you on again
it's great to be on again so okay let
let's talk about something that's very
much in the news right now a couple
weeks ago cnn reporter jim acosta
um just kind of showed up and approached
uh republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor greene on the street and and kind
of imposed a series of questions to her
about her supposedly not remembering
things she said in the aftermath of the
january sixth uh riots or in the
immediate
a period before it we now are in the
midst of people um
mostly pro-choice protesters showing up
at the houses of a few supreme court
justices and protesting at their homes
you also told me about a situation where
right-wing activist candace owens showed
up with a camera crew at the home of a
black lives matter uh
person i kind of want to talk through
your thoughts on these techniques and i
have a few thoughts on them although i i
don't have a sort of completely defined
opinion on them i guess first are these
things the three instances i just
mentioned
are they different or are they the same
in your mind and how would you approach
thinking about them
yeah that's it's interesting too i
haven't formulated my opinion on this
either
um
so i guess there's one distinction to
make is approaching someone on the
street as opposed to knocking on their
door
i'm not sure either is really worse than
the other although
you know one
in a sense knocking on my door is
more of an uh not quite an invasion of
my privacy but a a
sort of questioning of
coming closer to to my private space
on the other hand
i'm actually more protected behind my
front door than i am
on the street
and at a basic level it's
sort of no different than a jehovah's
witness coming and not knocking on my
front door and asking for some of my
attention i can simply say no there's
nothing illegal about it it's an
annoyance
and it's it's unplanned
and there there's something um
somewhat invasive about it
but
i can't say that there's actually
anything truly unethical about it that
would be my first pass at an opinion
it's the kind of thing that maybe i will
think less of the journalist who opts
for this as a plan a
but
on the other hand maybe they've reached
out to this person 10 times and the
person just won't engage with any media
despite being a public figure so as a
last resort
they're
sort of trying to catch them off guard
that last thing is interesting to me
because my instinct has generally been
okay this is not an approach i use we
make all sorts of interview requests and
sometimes they're ignored or sometimes
they're turned down and i sort of see
that as final like the person has turned
down their opportunity to talk to me
right but then at the same time
sometimes with public servants or with
people in positions that you're
appointed for life
you get the feeling as just a citizen
that they are in a sense beyond an
accountability that it feels like maybe
there should be so for example marjorie
taylor green
salary paid by the taxpayer you know
we'll talk more about that because that
could apply to postal workers too or you
know somebody at the dmv i don't know so
we'll talk about whether that's relevant
and
one of 435 legislators someone who has
an impact on policy and law etc and who
can just say i'm not going to answer
questions about what some believe was
her dishonesty at this hearing that took
place in georgia and so is it wrong as a
last resort for jim acosta to show up
there the supreme court justice
appointed for life
um essentially i mean short of some kind
of gross demonstrable
misdeed you you there's no recourse for
saying we're going to remove a supreme
court justice yes they can be impeached
but it doesn't happen
so then you show up at the house i don't
know that i'm like 98 of the way to this
is not okay
and then the how do you have
accountability is where i i kind of end
up thinking twice
right so you and i are in the same
position as people that interview a lot
of people
uh public figures i don't know how many
politicians necessarily but
we're in a position where we want to
talk to a lot of people that say no to
us and our audiences want us to talk to
a lot of people that say no to us true
and i completely agree with you never in
a million years would i show up at
someone's house so for instance
i i wrote an open letter to ibram x
kendi the author to have a conversation
with me and i in fact you know raised a
gofundme
uh i raised uh you know like 20 over 20
thousand dollars for a
a a charity
to connect the event to that cause and
he still didn't want to do it
and it's of a peace with his not wanting
to talk to any of his critics which i
think is a bad thing but never in a
million years would i show up at this
man's house or try to cost him on the
street
and i think it's because
well it's it's i guess it's no more
complicated than the golden rule like if
someone wanted to talk to me and i
didn't want to talk to them and they
showed up at my apartment
uh i would view that as
um
almost hostile right it's like
as
you can say that it's just the desire to
talk but it's the desire to talk
where they control the pace of
everything they knew they were they're
prepared i might be in my pajamas for
for all you know
um
and
it's it's also
close enough to a situation where there
is a mob outside my house
where it's it's uh
it's it's going to be very difficult for
me to be in a kind of relaxed state to
engage with you
on equal footing
it's a little bit like shooting downhill
it's like you have the high ground
in
in a battle situation
and i don't want to be really in that
position with someone i'm talking to so
there is something really strange and
uh
almost hostile about it
yeah i would say not even almost i mean
i don't know i was at a restaurant a
couple months ago and i told the story
and someone
was kind of i could tell that they
recognized me and then as i was leaving
they approached me and pretty loudly
they said you jew imperialist bastard
which didn't even accurately reflect my
views on the nuances of the
israeli-palestinian conflict as you can
imagine but nuances of imperialism yeah
uh that that was not um
that was not going to no matter what
that's not going to be a real
conversation and i think maybe part of
what you're getting at is if this is the
catalyst to start the conversation even
if it's only supposed to be a
conversation how good of one is it
really going to be
yeah yeah definitely which is i think
why
i wouldn't do it and probably why you
wouldn't do it but people that are
more into sensationalist sensationalist
journalism and
people for whom just getting the 60
second clip of whatever happens
is
their bread and butter um
now what about the people who just show
up
they're not journalists the ones showing
up at like you know kavanaugh's house or
whichever justice they're showing up at
they're saying well the supreme court
where all these people are here for life
have made a decision assuming we've been
told the truth of the decision that's
for coming they're making a decision i
don't like there's really no recourse
with these folks and you could say well
you've got to make sure at the state
level then that abortion stays legal
because there won't be a federal right
and it's it starts to become a well
maybe it is okay to show up at their
house although i would never do that
they would argue
what else can we really do
yeah so
in one sense
the
that's actually a feature not a bug of
american democracy is that the supreme
court
is supposed to be
insulated from that kind of intense
public pressure yes
um
you know they are one of the
institutions that separate america from
a direct democracy
by design
they're not supposed to be 100
responsive to public outrage or public
reaction they're supposed to be somewhat
insulated from that
so from that point of view
if you think um that feature of american
democracy is good then you probably
shouldn't show up outside a supreme
court justice's house
uh and you know yeah there are
i mean the point of democracy i think is
that we have these
i i really view democracy not as a
system that produces the best policies
all the time i think that's actually too
generous i think what it does better
than other systems of government
is channel the inevitable outrage of
different factions
into a non-violent
process which is if you can vote
it
releases a lot of the steam and anger
that
humans will always build up about
intense issues
and it's like it's like a release valve
on that steam where you can go to the
ballot box instead of the battlefield
and it's essentially a civil war
prevention mechanism in my view
and so when i see things inching closer
to
violence and uh which is not to say that
people
who who show up outside these folks
houses are violent but we know how these
things can sort of spill over sometimes
yep
um i do think it's it's worth
encouraging people to
you know reminding them that we do live
in a democracy you do have
um
you know electoral means of influencing
the laws in your state
and that's probably the wiser way to go
this sort of connects also to the issue
of i mean the the the sort of
prototypical situation is a speaker goes
to a college campus
and they were invited often it's by a
conservative group on campus which often
is the minority on campus i will readily
admit at least on some campuses it's the
minority and then there are
protesters against the speaker and
sometimes they're outside the building
but sometimes they're inside and will
rise up as the speech is about to start
and to me that's not really about free
speech per se in the sense of
nobody has a right to speak at a college
so not being invited is not a violation
of anything but at the same time
if you're invited it seems to me
that it's reasonable to expect that you
can at least get your thoughts out and
then during question and answer or
whatever but then the counter always is
when i kind of go this direction coleman
people saying it's not if you just stick
to the norms you'll never really get
anything done by definition activism
that has an impact
may be
inclusive of speech that isn't
comfortable or isn't being done exactly
when it's allowed and it gets to the
idea of the free speech zone that was
generated during george w bush's
presidency where yes you're allowed to
protest but in this box a hundred feet
from the venue for example how do you
think that ties in in terms of the
speech of the speaker
versus the speech of those who say i
don't like this speaker
yeah so the first thing i would say is i
think there's a big difference between
protesting
inside the event which drowns out the
speech okay and protesting outside at
columbia i witnessed lots of protests
like robust protests outside and those
um are totally totally valid
um and they get the point across they
definitely get the point across that a
lot of people object to the speaker
um
but i say you don't have the right to
just
interrupt any event that you want
because you hate the person and drown it
out
uh so but to your second point
this idea that you know you have to play
dirty to get things done right
and the other side is there's bigotry
and there's
evil and there's all this stuff so if we
play by the rules if we you know we're
just going to get whatever
i don't i really disagree with that i
mean if you look at
for one thing the most successful
protest movement i would argue in the
history of the country which was the
civil rights movement
they they
they took it very seriously to play by
certain norms
because they understood that it was
actually strategically important to do
so so for example
during the march on washington which was
uh organized by bayern rustin and
the famous 63 march on washington where
martin luther king gave the i have a
dream speech
buyer rustin at the end of that day he
went to a philip randolph
and
uh
like embraced him and congratulated him
on the fact that there was not a single
crime
at the whole event with thousands and
thousands of people you understand
what a difficult thing it is to manage
that like blm had so many
protests and i went to many in new york
where at the beginning
a local blm leader would say
this is a peaceful protest right they
would emphasize that with a bullhorn and
still
there would always be five or ten people
that ended up doing something crazy and
starting
right so it's incredibly difficult to
actually police the boundaries
within a protest and make sure no one
crosses those boundaries so that you
come across principled and persuasive to
people that don't already agree with you
i think many protesters they
underestimate the backlash phenomenon
which is when you go too far when you
demonstrate that you're willing to like
say you know like hit charles murray and
allison stenger when that happened at
oberlin right to initiate violence you
lose a lot of of good faith among
persuadable people that see you as
as
violent and dangerous revolutionaries
that should be in charge of nothing
right and and even if a lot of people
will only silently form that opinion i
think a lot of modern protest movements
fail to recognize that wisdom which
civil rights leaders really understood
deeply i guess that i i i'm generally
sensitive to that perspective
the the counter that i have is that
there are
non-insignificant there is a
non-insignificant contingent which will
frame any protest as violent anyway now
that doesn't justify any violence i'm
still against any violence and
criminality but also even if you say
okay well
we're not going to do any physical
violence but we will for example
shut down a road to make our presence
more known because if we just stay on
the sidewalk we're really not even going
to have the impact that we think we need
i think the concern is that there are
actors who will say whatever is being
done other than basically being
invisible is wrong and is a form of
violence regardless and then the
question becomes how do you deal with
the bad faith criticisms that will come
either way
yeah i mean
to me i think there is
you know if if i were
in charge of a protest movement sure
i think that this strategic wise route
is
to
demonstrate moral seriousness
that is um
you know every every protest movement
that has really
looked back on as something that made
major gains for society whether it be
gandhi in india or the civil rights
movement
or the marriage equality movement
it
key to their success was that they
demonstrated that they were
morally serious people that wanted to
improve and not simply
tear down
and the way to do that even if you're
even if you're disobeying the law in the
context of civil disobedience it's like
rosa parks disobeyed the law martin
luther king disobeyed the law they got
arrested dozens and dozens of times they
were in that sense they were not
um
i mean they they were not just
acquiescing to anything right they were
willing to disobey laws all the time but
precisely because they were doing that
they took very seriously the aim to
demonstrate that they were morally
serious people they were not disobeying
the law just to disobey the law they
were disobeying it because
they thought it needed to be changed and
they were right and it's um
again there are so many failed protest
movements protest movements that
that uh get very little accomplished i
think
it would be very unwise to not observe
the differences between the ones that
work and the ones that don't and that's
one of the big ones are there specific
so part of the examples you gave
as positively
include a sort of assessment by you
partially with the benefit of hindsight
now as to kind of the intentions and i'm
wondering in terms of tactics i mean
think sometimes in environmental
protests there's the
chaining oneself to x and sometimes it's
a tree or sometimes it's the fence at a
nuclear power plant or whatever the case
may be does the tactic itself tell you
much about
the the moral concern
yeah i think the tactic tells you a lot
about the moral concern so for instance
if the tactic this may be too obvious to
say but if the tactic is violent
it automatically
delegitimates the moral concern in most
people's eyes okay it's like if you're
even you know i guess this is a
unless
right so if you're just a terrorist
if you're an environmental terrorist and
you shoot somebody no one is going very
few people are going to be persuaded
right certainly congress is not going to
be persuaded
by that kind of a protest if your tactic
is non-violent
if you spell out exactly
what your principles are and why you're
violating some law
then
that demonstrates a kind of moral
seriousness and that's an actual appeal
to the public
right and and um moreover
to be willing to
suffer on on behalf of your principles
like to to
martin luther king was so committed to
non-violence
in a way that requires such extreme
restraint
right to literally be beaten and saying
that's the ultimate demonstration of
moral seriousness like i'm so serious
about this moral principle and getting
it in the right means that i'm willing
to subject myself to this
that was extremely persuasive to people
absolutely fascinating topic we've been
speaking with coleman hughes you can
check out coleman's podcast
conversations with coleman on which i am
a forthcoming guest uh coleman always
great chatting with you i appreciate
your time anytime
david follow us on social media interact
with the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
failed former president donald trump
claims he lost the four cell phones that
have just been subpoenaed by
leticia james uh i i know you you're
gonna say david how was that how is that
possible how is it possible he would
even try to say that but
there have been no consequences for
anything so why wouldn't he try to say
that look at this report from business
insider donald trump swears he has lost
four of the cell phones subpoenaed by
new york attorney general leticia james
what
former president donald trump swears he
can't find four personal and business
cell phones that new york's attorney
general has demanded for her probe of
the trump organization according to a
new court filing i am not aware of its
current location and i do not know its
current whereabouts trump says
repeatedly of his most recent recent
business phone two old flip phones plus
a samsung
that he had used until it was taken away
from me at some point while i was
president
trump also swears in the filing he has
no additional personal business
documents to turn over and he doesn't
own nor use a business computer
i also do not use a computer for work
related purposes that does appear to be
true that's been a thing for a while
there's actually a lot of ceos that
don't
use computers personally just to avoid
exactly this issue where their computer
might be requested for something uh the
affidavit was included as part of a
larger filing uh the former president
has been fined ten thousand a day
since april 26th when a manhattan judge
arthur engeron
issued a written order holding trump in
contempt of court for failing to comply
with the attorney general leticia
james's subpoenas for documents and
records trump currently owes more than a
hundred thousand dollars in fines he has
started appealing the contempt order
calling the fine exorbitant and
unjustified
trump was known during his presidency
for keeping a cell phone always at the
ready for the firing off of incendiary
tweets but in his affidavit trump says
he lost track of some of these old
devices including the very phones the
attorney general believes could contain
information pertinent to the inquiry
trump says he believes the trump
organization last issued him a business
phone in 2015 it's just gone it
disappeared i am no longer
this must be some kind of typo i am no
longer have the cell phone in my
possession and i am not aware of its
current location
as for two flip phones and the samsung
he has owned since 2010 those are also
lost i do not know their current
location
i took the samsung with me to the white
house and it was taken from me at some
point while i was president i do not
have the samsung in my possession i do
not know its current whereabouts
currently i own two personal mobile
phones one is an iphone he's had for
several years
and uh
he did submit that one for a uh for a
search so i mean listen does anyone
believe that he lost the four phones in
question no
no
but why not lie about it given that
there have been no consequences
whatsoever and that you're just trying
to run out the clock
um it seems as though you would
deliberately get rid of the phones that
that would be certainly one thing to do
and it may technically be true i mean if
you go by the letter he says he is not
aware of its current location that's
like if i say
uh i threw out a phone
it would be true that i am not aware of
its current location is it in a landfill
was it uh repurposed was it you know who
the hell knows it's technically true but
it's not the spirit of the situation so
as we've said before with almost all of
these different things
the strategy is obstruct
and delay the january 6th committee the
new york attorney general investigation
southern district all all these
different things that are going on
georgia
obstruct to the extent that you can and
make legal arguments as to why the
obstruction should be allowed and then
delay with january 6 we know the point
of delaying it is looking and i have to
choose my words carefully lest anyone in
the audience get mad at me it is looking
probable but it is not guaranteed that
republicans are going to take the house
in november and be sworn in to that
control in january if that happens the
january 6th committee is dead in the
water and of course anybody who has been
able to avoid dealing with the january 6
committee
you're good you're you're free
essentially and so that is the purpose
there and with a lot of these other
investigations you know in one of them
it started to become clear that there
was no real interest in charging trump
and investigators quit we covered that
story a few weeks ago
um so i don't believe any of it i don't
believe he lost the phones i mean if if
he doesn't know where they are it's
because they've been destroyed thrown
out whatever and it's technically
accurate but uh we know exactly what
they're doing and he will almost
certainly get away with it and we can
point fingers and say well it's just
merrick garland's fault or is it
it's actually far more complicated than
that there seems to be no genuine
willingness
to seriously consider charging the
president and immediate associates and
that has opened the door for them to do
whatever they can at the time to justify
not cooperating that's exactly what
trump is doing now with this for lost
cell phone thing
so in the midst of so many negative and
horrible things happening around the
world i'm going to take just a brief
break for something that's admittedly
not that important in the grand scheme
of things i mean listen we've got
ukraine
we have a shaky economy when it comes to
the stock market and inflation although
jobs numbers are good we have the
resurgence of covid again i mean it yes
it's it's happening yet all these
different things i get that what i'm
about to tell you is not of utmost
importance but it's nice to have
something good going on
the david pakman show youtube channel
has achieved and surpassed
[Music]
1.45 million subscribers meaning we are
now pushing
very close to a million and a half
subscribers okay
now i know
mr beast
xqc
pokemane
you know these are major streamers that
make our numbers look small but we're
not in their space okay we're in the
independent left media political space
and 1.5 million subscribers in that
space is actually a really big deal
you've got the young turks our friends
at the young turks with over 5 million
subscribers
incredible achievement
they're a dramatically larger
organization than us at one point i
think they had close to 100 employees i
don't know where they are right now but
orders of magnitude different size
organization than the david pakman show
we're tiny in comparison and yet
we are riding up to being only the
second show
in the left media space to hit the
milestone of 1.5 million it's the young
turks
and then
in theory it could be us if we get there
we're not putting anybody down
right i mean
if you just look around you look at
other people in our space you've got a
bunch that are over a million you've got
some just under some closer to 500 000.
right now there is one major left
youtube show over a million and a half
and that's the young turks
if and when we get there we would be the
second so this is hugely exciting and
based on recent growth we're sort of on
target to hit 1.5 million about a month
before the midterms it'd be right in the
first half of october is the way it's
looking right now however
it's not impossible that we could do it
way more quickly right now we're about
45 000 youtube subscribers away from a
million if we wanted to hit that
milestone
by the summer equinox june 21 we would
need about a thousand subscribers a day
we've done that at other other times
usually it's like right before a
presidential election but it's not
inconceivable that we could do that even
just to hit by september 1st that shaves
about 40 days off
uh we only need about 400 subscribers a
day that's very very doable it's only
slightly faster than we're tracking
right now it is wild to look at old
numbers and to see how far we've come
the david pakman show launched on
youtube
uh in 2009
thanks to jenk yuger many people don't
know this story but in 08 i met jenk at
a talk radio conference because at the
time
talk radio was still big doing youtube
was the weird thing
and i met jenk and he said i told him
what i was doing at the time we were
doing a podcast and a radio show and he
said i would figure out just film
figure out how to film
and um
see what happens
and it took us five years to get our
first hundred thousand subscribers
it took five full years just to get to
that first milestone
and then the next hundred thousand took
only a year and five months and then the
next hundred thousand was even quicker
and it's crazy that now
we might be able to add 45 000
subscribers in just a couple of months
and hit this insane milestone of a
million and a half subscribers so i
can't thank you enough everybody if
you're in that 1.45 million right now
thank you
and i'm coming to you for help and ideas
first make sure that you're subscribed
and second if you have ideas of how else
we might be able to accelerate the
milestone write in and let us know info
davidpakman.com i'm always up for doing
something extra something exciting and
people said at a million i should bleach
my hair blonde but we never got it in
place it was like we were at like 990
when someone suggested it i don't know
that anybody really cares about that
i would be up for that and i would be up
for filming it if it was interesting
we'd have to put a challenge on it right
like if we make it to the 1.5 million
by august 1st or something like that but
i'm up for whatever people want to write
in info davidpakman.com so let me know
your ideas we'll get something in place
and very very exciting stuff not the
most important thing in the world i
understand but with so many negative
things going on it's nice to have
something positive going on we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
david p
uh
we um i this is kind of a funny
voicemail i got my radical trumpists
confused on i guess
yesterday we were talking about people
associated with trumpism who were
running in 2022. and i got my trumpists
confused listen to
hi david just watching your show and i
wanted to make a
small correction
j.r majewski isn't from michigan he's
from ohio's ninth congressional district
and the other guy that you interviewed
from michigan was john gibbs
i'm sure they all just kind of run
together after a while yeah just wanted
to let you know thank you bye yeah
that's actually exactly what happened i
was kind of just going from memory about
various trumpets we've interviewed and
spoken to and whatever i got the states
wrong so i apologize there but they're
all still radical nuts
but i did get the states wrong and for
that i apologize because we want
accuracy
and precision both on this program we
have a great bonus show for you today we
are going to talk about what's happening
in the elections in the philippines it
is absolutely fascinating and i think it
will be of interest to many in our
audience we are going to talk about the
new biden administration proposal to cap
the cost of the internet
for low-income americans of internet
service to be clear
and it seems natural that we would do
this and yet there are many people that
are completely furious about it so we're
going to talk about that and we are also
going to talk more about abortion rights
activists demonstrating outside the
homes of supreme court justices we have
some opinions about whether that's okay
to do or not we are going to get more
opinions about that producer pat will
join me we're going to talk about ambush
journalism protesting at people's houses
all these types of things uh and there
really are very different views about if
and when if ever
and when these tactics are okay to use
all of those stories and more are on
today's bonus show we do a bonus show
every day for our members you can sign
up and become a member at
joinpackman.com
and you can use the coupon code obama
to become a member that's obama
and just remember alex jones hates the
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad so
just as long as you're comfortable
supporting something alex jones hates
sign up at coinpackman.com and i will
see you then